hey by the way Old Dirty Bastard helped
a kid out the other day did you hear
about this no what happened you saved a
little girl's life the other day didn't
you yes you did he you know listen to
this some girl was hit by a car uh-huh
dirty lifted the car off of her like
Superman what yeah he mobilized an
effort to rescue this girl did you read
about in the paper no yeah I I read
about it tell me what happened there um
seriously that was beautiful all I could
say is I thank God yeah you saw the girl
get hit by the car right no actually I
didn't actually see her get hit by the
car
but um this was not one of your own
children though right I love all the
children right equally yes um you know
she was um I saw people you know over
there going a little wild and I was
wondering what's going on so I jump out
my car and um where was this by the way
my um it was 4 Street in Brooklyn right
I just stopped my car in the middle of
the street and I ran towards the car I'm
saying what's going on everybody talking
so fast and moving so fast it's like
spontaneous reaction it was like you
remember back in the days they had
that's incredible yes it was like
remember when the girl snatched the door
open yeah you get Incredible strength
sometimes in a moment of panic yes and
you lifted the car off the Girl by
yourself know he got some people there
some people there you know and it just
happened you know and and then you were
at her side in the hospital were you not
yes beautiful beautiful man I applaud
you for that that's great bang Clan
number one I mean other than this rap
business you know that's the important
stuff yes that's the very important
stuff you're like Superman for Christ's
sake I swear to God you really are this
should be uh a movie about
him